these are the times that try men's souls
the summer soldier and the sunshine
patriot will in this crisis
shrink from the service of their country
but he that stands by it now
deserves the love and thanks of man and
woman for some reason those words of
thomas paine
just happened to run through my mind
this morning
president trump if you were up with us
we were up all night and then we
came home and wrote a little bit of my
show and now we're back here again
president trump was doing very very well
much better than any pollster thought
by a long shot he more or less tore down
modern polling last night and just as
everything seemed
like it was going to finalize and clinch
for trump
it all stopped for some reason it all
just it all just stopped
people stopped counting the votes
everyone went home for the night
we didn't go home for the night we were
all still watching all of you were still
up and watching
and yet for some reason the people
counting the votes
in key counties around this country
i don't know they just stopped we will
try to find out why i'm michael knowles
this the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from top 10 guy one
who said
i would trust an astrology witch over a
cnn pollster
at this point i i didn't hear the
difference between you said
i would trust an astrology witch over in
astrology which is that which i don't
know
i don't know what the difference could
be there this was the
theme of my show yesterday and it was
100 vindicated
last night which is i said that modern
polling
modern statistics modern social science
is a psyop it is a farce
it is part of a system that we could
call it the liberal establishment we
could name
the legacy media the administrative
state the higher education
the universities i i said this whole
system
exists to preserve itself it is
the minute there's a crack in the system
the whole thing is going to fall apart
and i said the polls were unreliable and
turns out they were unreliable
and now it sure looks like there are
some shenanigans going on we will give
you the absolute
latest numbers because we got to make
sure that we can protect
the ballot box and you know what you got
to make sure that you can protect
your car a car shield is a great way to
do that okay with car shield i don't
have to worry about
all that kind of stuff when you see that
check engine light come on that can
really worry you car shield offers a
wide range of protection plans that can
save you thousands for a covered repair
you have the freedom to choose your
favorite mechanic or dealership to do
the work and car shield gets the rest
taken care of even if your car breaks
down while you're traveling
the choice of a repair shop is still up
to you car shield has helped
over do you know how many do you know
how many one million drivers
that's why they are america's number one
auto protection company
it's a real hassle this happened to me
about a year and a half ago
where i had some car trouble so i go and
i fix the car trouble
i spent a lot of money doing it then i
start driving what happens that check
engine goes on the car starts shaking
costs a lot more money then it costs a
lot more then i gotta get rid of the car
i wish at that time i had car shield
okay i used i used to dread car repairs
with car shield
i have peace of mind get coverage today
see why car shield cars go
farther call 800-665-2157
mention code knowles or visit
carshield.com and use code knowles to
save 10
that is car shield dot com code knowles
a deductible may apply
you'll notice if you are watching this
rather than listening that i
am doing something very unusual i have
my computer out
i don't like to have my computer out
usually during the show i feel
like it separates me from you so i
usually just use my printed notes but i
have to have my computer up right now
because we're getting the latest numbers
in from the count so when i woke up this
morning
president trump was leading in michigan
by a slim margin
i'll just let's just go through the
states that matter right now so for some
reason they still have not called
georgia for president trump early on it
was clear that georgia was for trump now
it may i guess it seems less clear trump
still has a commanding
104 000 vote lead there
with 92 of the estimated votes
reported and and and he's up very
significantly
i have no idea why they're not calling
georgia yet the same thing goes
for north carolina trump is up almost
100 000 votes
in north carolina pretty commanding lead
for some reason
they won't call that their either it was
so
clear on election night that the country
was going for trump in a decisive
way and then it all stopped arizona
right now
seems to be the opposite sort of
situation biden does appear to have a
commanding lead
in arizona nobody is really questioning
those results
right now but some of the other states
people are questioning pretty
significantly
right now joe biden is up less than 8
000 fewer than 8 000 votes
in nevada it's incredibly tight right
now
uh nevada is uh it would be very helpful
to president trump's reelection
wisconsin the race is about 20 000 votes
apart right now
just imagine how slim that margin is
20 000 votes is still an incredibly slim
margin and then in some places you're
talking about eight or ten thousand
votes
joe biden has that narrow narrow lead in
wisconsin
again that didn't look that way last
night but now that we're all waking up
this morning
it would appear that way michigan right
now
which was for trump when i when i woke
up is now
separated by 12 000 votes 12
000 votes basically unheard of
just that slim margin for joe biden in
pennsylvania trump has a commanding lead
good trump is up
600 000 votes in pennsylvania with 76
percent of estimated votes reported
and yet they won't call it for trump
they won't call it for trump because if
trump has pennsylvania if he has north
carolina if he has georgia
puts him in a very good place he still
probably has to win
uh wisconsin or michigan but puts him in
a very very strong position
they won't call those trump states and
there seems to be
some irregularities going on in other
places as well
even liberal outlets admitted that it
was weird last night
when they stopped counting the votes
allegheny county pennsylvania suspended
the scanning of mail-in ballots
last night and they they said that they
were going to postpone it until
10 a.m local time unheard of that was
according to nbc
fulton georgia stopped counting mail-in
ballots after a burst
water pipe delayed the counting of about
50 000 ballots
that was according to the new york times
burst water pipe you don't say
did your dog eat the mail in ballots too
joe biden because he had to get to bed
he was probably already in bed before
but he got out
last night about i don't know what was
it about our time maybe
11 o'clock or earlier even joe biden
comes on stage
very positive very hopeful and
to my mind a little too confident we
feel good about where we are
we really do
[Applause]
i'm here to tell you tonight we believe
we're on track to win this election
we knew because of the unprecedented
early vote in the mail-in vote
that's going to take a while we're going
to have to be patient
until we uh the hard work of tallying
the votes is finished
and it ain't over until every vote is
counted every ballot is counted
but we're feeling good we're feeling
good about where we are
by the way that's that's not true what
he just said well i'm sure he is feeling
good and i think he's got a lot of
reason to feel good
for instance the attorney general of
pennsylvania promised him that he would
win the state
before election day promised it to him
isn't that autumn a man who is going to
be involved
in some of the litigation surrounding
pennsylvania
an elected official in that state
promising him
that state joe biden said that it's not
over until all the votes are counted
that may end up being true but that
ought not to be true according to the
rules
because what if i vote after election
day what if i vote two days after
election day what if i vote in december
christmas eve i decide you know i think
i'm going to vote for trump today
is that vote going to be counted no you
have to vote on time
but unfortunately the supreme court blew
up
those sorts of deadlines and now even
worse than that we're in a situation
where in pennsylvania
the votes may not even have to be
postmarked
there's a world in which they could just
find
i don't know ten thousand votes that's
pretty slim margins in these places
ten thousand twenty thousand thirty
thousand votes if the postmark is
smudged if it's unclear what the
postmark is
they could just count those votes we
know that there have been irregular
elections before this happened notably
a number of years ago with al franken
before he got booted out of the senate
but
when he was brought into the senate all
it looked like the republicans were
winning on election night
and all of a sudden a couple hundred
thousand mail-in votes just show up
they go overwhelmingly implausibly
some pundits have suggested
statistically impossibly
for the democrat and then the democrat
wins the race and republicans rolled
over
in that case joe biden seemed very
very confident president trump seemed
less confident when he walked in
to give his speech he he didn't seem
happy now by the way
joe biden gave a speech much earlier
than than
donald trump did president trump walks
in and gave a speech at 2 30 in the
morning
this is a 74 year old man who had
coronavirus what two weeks ago
and and he came in and he gave his
speech
and he he said as he predicted as we
predicted on this show
this is going to the courts and did i
predict this
newt did i say this i've been saying
this from the day i
heard they were going to send out tens
of millions of ballots they said exactly
because either they were going to win or
if they didn't win
they'll take us to court for the good of
this nation this is a very big moment
this is a major fraud in our nation
we want the law to be used in a proper
manner
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
we want all voting to stop
we don't want them to find any ballots
at
four o'clock in the morning and add them
to the list okay
it's it's a very sad it's a very sad
moment to me this is a very sad moment
and
we will win this and we as far as i'm
concerned we already have fallen
so i just want to thank you
there it is there is the line that's
that's getting president trump in
trouble
i want to go through because there are
people who are attacking him for this
even on the right we had a little
disagreement on the
daily wire set last night about about
what to make of this statement there are
a couple statements in here that are
worth parsing
because i 100 defend what the president
just said there
and i know that's that some of the
things that he said oh there they make
us feel a little squeamish
he's already getting fact checked
they're calling him a liar i i don't
think
that he said a single lie in that
statement
but in in the terms of the facebook fact
checkers it requires
context fine i'm more than happy to give
that context you know
context is so important to understand
the issues of our day it's important to
education
generally and uh one great way to to get
that
is homeschool magnet home school magnet
supports homeschooling families
by providing students with instruction
from world class
credentialed teachers in a remote
classroom with their peers
parents choose the best teachers for
each student based on
values and teaching approach to ensure
every child is receiving
exactly the education that they desire
this puts
you as the parent in full control of
your child's education
without the daily responsibilities of
lesson planning pre-learning
teaching tutoring and grading each
student will receive
instruction in the four core subject
areas of math
english language arts and gender studies
no i'm kidding not gender studies
there's math english language arts
science and social studies
this approach is similar to most remote
college learning formats
and will help prepare students for
secondary school with homeschool magnet
you get the freedom and control of
homeschooling without the burden
homeschool magnet is only a fraction of
the cost of private schools
and the 30-day money-back guarantee upon
enrollment means this choice is
risk-free i know a lot of people
are looking into various home school
programs ways to augment home school
programs right now especially
as students are being totally failed by
public schools more so than usual
a lot of people are at home right now
this is a great way
to augment your child's education to
learn more about homeschool magnets
student experience
go to homeschoolmagnet.com join the
growing wait list
for interested teachers who want more
freedom in their teaching career
homeschool magnet may be the perfect fit
for you
they're recruiting teachers right now so
visit homeschoolmagnet.com
michaelmich ael to learn more and apply
ties in pretty well disrupting the
education space ties in very well
to disrupting the other established
institutions which seem to raid against
president trump right now
what president trump said is that this
is a big fraud being perpetrated on the
american people
that is true he's being fact checked for
it because they're saying well we don't
know if the election is fraudulent we
don't know if there are fraudulent votes
right now in
pennsylvania or in wisconsin or in
michigan or nevada who knows
that's not the point last night the
election was going for trump the left
had already set the stage for this
because they i guess suspected that
nobody was going to vote
for that daughtering old crook uh
even though they had the advantage of
early voting and mail-in voting before
before the second presidential debate
before the new york post story showing
the biden family corruption even before
that i think the left thought
gosh maybe we're not going to win this
thing so we need to set the stage we'll
say it's a red mirage trump's going to
win on election night
and then we're going to keep on counting
we're going to keep on counting until we
win
that's the language you heard from joe
biden he said when every vote is counted
then we're going to win you heard this
from josh shapiro the crooked
a.g of pennsylvania obviously deeply
corrupt man
he said when all the votes are counted
biden's going to win how are you so sure
attorney general
do you know something that we don't know
the fraud that was perpetrated last
night was that
important counties in this country
stopped counting
why did they stop i don't know i guess
one place where they had a they had a
water problem i don't know some water
was coming out i was a piper saying
whatever anyway
see in 10 hours unheard of
have you heard of that happening in
presidential races particularly close
presidential races
the problem with stopping that kind of
counting in those places
is it gives the opportunity for fraud
it at least gives the image of fraud the
suspicion
of fraud and we know that there have
been elections in this country's history
where ballots magically appear we're
unsuspected
unexpected ballots magically appear that
is a fraud
what president trump said there there is
a fraud being proven that's the fraud
at the very least all the fact checkers
we can all agree
that is going on then president trump
came to his controversial line he said i
think we're going to win
as far as i'm concerned we already have
some people are split up we were split
on the daily wire set about this last
night
i think it's absolutely fine to make
that statement now
we don't know if he's won yet even
taking the fraud question out of it
the later election fraud or their or
their fraudulent votes being counted
we don't know that he's won yet but the
qualifier as far as i'm concerned
is an important qualifier here joe biden
also said i think we're on the path to
victory i think we're looking good when
all the votes are kind of we're going to
win he said all that kind of stuff
president trump says it and he says a
little more strongly that's a big deal
as far as i'm concerned we've already
won the reason that i will defend this
even though we don't know for certain
if he's already won is because you have
to look
at the context of this election you want
to add context facebook let's add
context
the reason to object to that statement
is if we lived
in a world in which people had full
faith in these poll counters
in the mainstream media that's reporting
it in the
elected officials who are going to be
governing this this election
in the deep state the administrative
state that's involved
if we had faith in those if we could
trust those if those had credibility
then i would say okay back off maybe
we'll just wait and see hold your breath
we'll wait and see
but they don't have any credibility and
it's not just me who doesn't believe in
them
nobody believes in them the pollsters
completely completely humiliated
themselves last night the mainstream
media completely humiliated themselves
last night the legacy media so
they they have no credibility whatsoever
you had
officials in these states people
involved in the election
with the hashtag resist on their twitter
account well that doesn't sound great
you had allegations of irregularities
going on much earlier
you had an issue of mail-in voting a
local affiliate in philadelphia did an
experiment sent out 100 mail-in ballots
to a dummy po box they got two birthday
cards which means the wires got crossed
somewhere and three ballots went missing
three percent
sure can swing an election especially
when we're talking about numbers the
likes of which we're talking about here
that's not a good sign
you have the problem of widespread
unsolicited mail-in ballots
unprecedented in this country's history
people say there's no evidence that that
leads to fraud
there can't be evidence it's never
happened we've never had that system
before
obviously opened a fraud you had you had
claims of people getting
ballots for their dead pets and
certainly for dead relatives
you you heard stories of ballots going
missing jeremy boring's ballot went
missing i believe here in california
obviously open to abuse
and then you have the piester resistance
the cherry on top of the sundae
they stop the freaking counting
why i don't know maybe trump's numbers
were just looking too good
that's what it seemed like to us on the
election map
they wouldn't call states the the left
wing and the legacy media wouldn't call
florida trump was up by about a
zillion points in florida what's the
final tally is up almost 400 000 votes
in florida with 96 percent
of estimated votes reported they still
wouldn't call it it was so clear early
on
that we flipped congressional districts
in that state for goodness sakes
so it looks a little suspicious
and what and you had a narrative being
pushed out by the establishment media
by the administrative government by
bureaucrats by establishment left-wing
politicians
all being pushed by big technology which
was censoring the president
suppressing conservative views
and what president trump did was counter
that narrative
joe biden doesn't have to do that he can
walk out their tickety-boo
he can say yes i feel confident about
how we're doing he doesn't have to say
that
because he's got an entire system
working for him to push the narrative
that he already won
even though there is zero evidence that
he already won zilch
nada and a lot of evidence to the
contrary
so you've got that entire apparatus
pushing biden's the pro-biden message
and you got one dude named donald trump
pushing his message
trying to counter that narrative from
deeply corrupt institutions with no
credibility whatsoever
so yeah i'm going to give him a little
bit of grace i'm going to give him the
opportunity
to make that argument the election isn't
over yet i'm not claiming the election
is over yet
i don't think president trump is
claiming it either
he was making a narrative point he says
as far as i'm concerned we have one
we'll see we're going to the supreme
court we're going to stop some of these
irregularities
but let's even let's just grant that
sure he went a little far
he made an extreme statement okay you've
got
every single mouthpiece in the world
pushing biden propaganda
totally dubious if not outright
dishonest biden propaganda and you've
got donald trump and
many conservatives or will undercut
donald trump on this fine that's their
prerogative
but you got this guy alone basically
and he's the one doing it i absolutely
give him
grace on that he also had a lot of
energy last night i got to tell you
he had 2 30 in the morning this guy he's
got a lot of energy he must have been
very well
hydrated and if you want to be well
hydrated you got to check out liquid iv
liquid iv is a new hydration has a new
hydration multiplier plus immune support
this is cutting edge blend of vitamin c
vitamin d
zinc and well-immune and convenient
single serving packets
vitamin c well known to protect your
body and support good health
vitamin d facilitates immune system
function very important these days and
improves your daily defense
zinc the second most abundant trace
mineral in your body
supports your immune cell health and
function very very important these days
well immune is a naturally sourced beta
glucan that
is proven to help strengthen your immune
system
sometimes i know some friends of mine
who are athletes they love liquid iv
because you know it helps hydrate you
must much more quickly i'm not exactly
you know
going out there running down the
football court or whatever whatever one
does
but if you go out maybe you have a
couple coca-colas maybe with your
buddies on the backstage set last night
until midnight
and you need some hydration you need a
little bit of that liquid iv great place
to go
the new hydration multiplier plus immune
support is available at walmart where
you can order online get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code
michael at checkout that is 25 off
anything you
order when you use promo code michael
liquid iv.com get better hydration today
at liquidity.com promo code michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l
you want to talk about the corruption in
this race we mentioned josh shapiro the
the attorney general of pennsylvania
calling pennsylvania for biden before
election day
you know what else he did he tweeted out
he said if you need help with your
mail-in ballot
finding out where to vote or something
else call the pennsylvania democrats
voter assistance hotline
someone will answer and help you out
call 1-833 pa
votes the attorney general of
pennsylvania
sending out the democrat hotline if
people want information on
how and where to vote something stinks
in pennsylvania and i
i think people are going to be rightly
very skeptical
if all of a sudden biden or trump's
commanding lead rather goes to biden
people are going to be very very
skeptical all right what's the update on
the numbers i'm going to take a quick
pause to update on the numbers and we'll
get
back to this absolutely crooked system
that is working overtime against trump
because don't forget
trump wasn't supposed to win in 2016. he
wasn't supposed to win
and then he did proving all of these
statisticians and social scientists and
and liberal elites
proving them all to be complete fools in
2016
and they spent four years trying to
overturn it first of all the
the obama administration and the deep
state associated with his administration
spied on trump to try to end that
election when that didn't work they
spent three and a half years
trying to force a coup d'etat on him
they tried impeachment that didn't work
either the mueller investigation that
didn't work either
and now it's all just so cute it's a
little too cute for me how this is
turning out
michigan right now you've got a
difference of 9 000 votes
9 000 votes but joe biden just over the
edge
that's convenient wisconsin 20 still
about 20 000 votes in wisconsin i don't
think that number has been updated
nevada still 8 000 votes
in nevada i don't think that number's
been updated either pennsylvania trump
still has a commanding lead
unfortunately for the new york times and
538 and the other
old establishment press and polling
outlets they haven't been able to erase
that lead
from trump yet again trump's still up
bigly in georgia
trump's still up bigly in north carolina
a little a little bit tighter in north
carolina but we're still talking about
80 000 votes so
we're still pretty good pretty good spot
let's say hypothetical worst case
scenario
that nevada
just barely just squeaks by for biden
we're talking about 8 000 votes or so
wisconsin just squeaks by for biden
20 000 votes or so michigan just oh
just barely squeak spy for buying 9 000
votes or so
who knows what they're going to try to
pull on pennsylvania
will everybody feel confident in the
results of that
election ask yourself i'm not i'm not
telling you what to think
will you feel confident in that given
all of the
irregularities this year the
unprecedented types of voting
the way that hillary clinton said joe
biden should not concede under any
circumstances
the way that attorneys general other
elected officials have been so confident
the way that joe biden himself is so
confident can every vote we're going to
win
there's joe biden with that signature
wink i think the odds of that is
something like
flipping a coin and getting heads three
four times in a row
not saying it's impossible it's not
impossible
but it is unlikely it is unlikely pretty
strange
a little too cute if there are
shenanigans going on
perhaps people perhaps the people
involved in that
should have built themselves a wider
margin of error maybe they couldn't
maybe they're just rubbing our faces in
it who knows we do know that big tech
is censoring president trump they
immediately did this
big technology censoring the president
of the united states
on election night as far as i'm
concerned
so i know that phrase is uh
controversial now but as far as i'm
concerned
the government can break up twitter
twitter is has committed a fraud
they've committed a fraud on how people
use that
platform had they gained the control of
the public square
and our public discourse right you
thought you were getting one thing you
were getting another you thought you
were getting
a an open platform where you could
follow people and actually get their
tweets and say what you want to say
and then you've got something else more
akin to a publisher which brings us into
another fraud they're getting liability
protection
through section 230 the communications
decency act shouldn't be getting that
and though twitter i don't think has a
monopoly big tech generally has a
monopoly on information
break it up break it up i don't want to
hear any
ridiculous frivolous arguments about how
it's a private company
well sort of private companies aren't
allowed to commit fraud first of all
they're not allowed to get
uh liability protection that they're
they're not deserving of that they that
they are not
abiding by the rules of but as a broader
political issue
this system is crumbling
the legacy media has completely
declined itself the pollsters are done
there is no reason to listen to these
pollsters again but
certain vestiges of it remain namely big
tech
big tech still has a lot of power
and we're checking these numbers even as
they come in
you've got to break that up you've got
to break up these big technology
companies
what they censored here is that
president trump
said we are up big but they're trying to
steal the election we will never let
them do it votes cannot be cast after
the polls are closed
they said some or all of this content
shared in the street is disputed and
yeah disputed by twitter because they're
upset because they don't want to be
found out
might be misleading about an election or
other civic process hillary clinton said
one of the leaders of the democratic
party said biden shouldn't concede under
any circumstances
elected officials said joe biden won
before election day
is that not that's not sufficient
evidence that some
people in this country are trying to
steal the election obviously some people
i'm not saying everybody's trying to
steal the election i'm not saying that
the election is going to be stolen i'm
not saying that either
but some people are trying to do it
which trump said 100 right doesn't
matter they're going to censor him for
it
you had ever you had everything when i
think about
do i give the grace and the benefit of
the doubt to this establishment
or do i give the grace and the benefit
of the doubt to trump
keep this in mind they're threatening
political violence
they were already doing it they were
boarding up shops not because of riotous
brooks brothers clad conservatives
because of leftists and by the way they
already began perpetrating violence
last night there the violence already
broke out as the early
votes came in and it seemed to be going
for trump we are in an incredibly tight
race
we have kept you in the loop every step
of the way with all of yesterday's
coverage
and last night's coverage and this
morning's coverage and i don't know
maybe i'll sleep next week
it is still too soon to tell who will
win ultimately who will be declared the
president ultimately
so join daily wire now and get 25 off
with code election
so that you can keep up with us on all
of the unfolding twists and turns
but not only that we have big plans for
these next four years regardless of who
the president turns out to be
i am very pleased to announce that
candace owens new york times bestselling
author
founder of the blexit movement will be
launching a brand new show with us early
next year in nashville
as well as writing content for us over
at dailywire.com
you know we we've been friends with
candace for years now back when she was
still like
a smaller youtube celebrity back before
she really blew up
and we would have her on the shows and
you know we've been we've been pals with
her for a long time
so excited to have her over here we'll
also be launching an entertainment
channel
a new investigative journalism team and
building partnerships
with like-minded content creators like
prageru i guess we already have a
partnership because i host a show over
there
a prageru's entire show library will be
available to dailywire.com members
by the end of the year that is 25 off
your daily wire membership with code
election
when you sign up today head on over
there we'll be right back with a lot
more
we're not really getting any updates to
the numbers right now
probably those uh i don't know those
counters just haven't gotten back yet
it's been about what 10 hours since they
left in some of these places and
maybe they'll maybe they'll get ready
eventually who knows maybe there will be
more ballots to count
who knows violence last night already
broke out when it looked like trump was
winning violence at black lives matter
plaza which is so weird because blm is
such a peaceful organization
so weird that violence would break out
at blm plaza take a listen
oh
[Music]
you get the idea people smacking each
other in their head with bats
this is humiliating the greatest
democracy on earth
looks like a third world banana republic
that can't conduct its own elections
that boards up shops that has people
beating each other in the streets if it
looks like the orange man is going to
win
that has the widespread
belief that there is fraud going on
i'm not even saying that necessarily
there is fraud there's some evidence for
it
but the widespread belief i mean this is
true of both sides of the aisle i think
there's no evidence that there would be
fraud on the pro-trump side
but the left was prattling on about that
because they always accuse us of what
they're doing
and there is evidence things going on
you know that pennsylvania attorney
general pretty weird
way they stopped the county pretty weird
there is evidence of that you have
a situation right now where neither side
is going to believe that they lost
that is a great shame for the united
states once the world's greatest
democracy i guess it still
is is it we can't conduct elections this
would be the second election in 20 years
that we haven't been able to conduct
that we haven't been able to
know who the winner is we're headed back
as we
predicted on this show we're headed back
to a bush v
gore kind of situation and and i'd like
to even make a kind of
slight defense of the people who maybe
are committing fraud
i'm not i'm not really defending them i
think fraud is essentially the worst sin
you can commit
dante puts the people way way down in
the pits of hell who commit fraud
but part of
the argument if you're a left winger if
you're one of these crooked officials
for if you if you have the opportunity
tipping the hand to biden rather than
trump
is because you believe that trump is
literally hitler and and
if frankly worse than hitler i mean you
had prominent
left-wingers who go on cnn saying in the
past few days that trump is worse than
hitler
and you've had joe biden himself saying
that donald trump will
destroy the world
not the country not the decade
the world joe biden tweeted this out you
want to talk about irresponsible
rhetoric here joe biden tweeted this out
he said
if we give donald trump another four
years in the white house our
planet will never recover
what does that even mean i guess he's
talking about global warming
but actually under the trump
administration we've cut our uh our
emissions
if they were worried about carbon
dioxide we actually cut it we cut it
more than the people who signed onto
that stupid paris climate accord that
biden's always talking about that he
says he would want to get us
back into so it doesn't what does he
mean he's talking about something
i think more metaphysical a little more
religious
that trump is basically the embodiment
of evil
and you see this the the left that
doesn't believe in the incarnation of
goodness generally the secular left the
atheist left right christianity
if you were to use very abstract terms
to describe it is you have the
incarnation of goodness itself of
love itself in christ the second person
of the trinity
and the entire religion obviously is
oriented toward
him the left doesn't seem to have that
they don't seem to have
an understanding of the the
incarnational goodness
they have the opposite they have the
understanding of incarnational
evil so you know
trump is literally hitler or hit you
know a hitler obviously is you know very
evil man but they'll ignore the evil of
stalin they'll ignore the evil
of mao they'll ignore the evil of fidel
castro they'll ignore the evil
of their guys and but they will they
will
ascribe pure incarnational evil
uh to to other people and it's selective
and they've done it to trump i mean it's
i i i feel like i'm being hyperbolic
when i say they compare trump to hitler
but they know
they've actually done more they said
he's worse than hitler so they only have
that sense of
of incarnational evil and if you believe
that if you believe that trump is
literally
the physical manifestation of evil
a pure evil then sure you'd probably rig
a vote or two
to to throw the election against him
and i'm not saying that's what's
happening there might be a little
evidence of irregularities there might
be a greater vulnerability to it because
of unprecedented
unsolicited wise red male and votes
i'm just saying if that were to happen i
would understand
given the left premises why they do that
we do have some good news that came out
regardless of of what happens in this
presidential race or court battle i
guess it's a court battle at this point
the good news is that the the experts
were wrong about everything again the
experts
told us that trump's a racist right he
won't condemn white supremacy he's done
it seven million times but he won't
condemn white supremacy he's a racist he
started his campaign on racism
he called mexicans rapists and murderers
and whatever else
trump is doing better among hispanic
voters and black voters than any
republican in modern history and he's
doing better now than he was before
in 2016 even in 2016
donald trump got a lower share of the
white vote
than mitt romney had and white turnout
was stagnant it didn't grow from 2012
with romney to 2016 with trump
don't let anybody tell you trump is the
avatar of the
white nationalist white supremacist
romney did better among whites
than donald trump did in 2016.
and he got trump got a higher percentage
of black and hispanic voters
he got three percent more hispanic voter
african-american voters and he got two
percent more hispanic voters
which tilted some of those states
wisconsin ohio
florida pennsylvania tilted them toward
trump so according to the exit polls and
again take it with a grain of salt
but they're much better than the
prediction polls according to the exit
polls
president trump did better in 2020 with
every single race and sex
except for white guys it's uh it's like
perfectly backwards from what the
the establishment legacy apparatus has
told us
trump down five points with
white men which we're told as his
exclusive base no
he's down with white men he's up two
points with white women but i thought
the suburban women were going to go
against trump and doesn't really look
that way
up four points with black men that's
actually pretty significant
up four points with black women very
significant because there was some
evidence that trump was going to go
some i don't even know if you can call
it evidence now because the polls are
bunk
but there were some signs that president
trump was going to do better with black
men but he's going to do worth of black
women no he's up four points with both
of them according to exit polls
he's up three points with latino men
three points with latino women
up five points with other i don't know
who falls into other but he's up five
points
with them who knows maybe the polls will
be wrong
again let's check in here and see if
we've got any change to the votes
we've got uh okay um
no okay looks like the there does seem
to be more counting going on right now
in michigan looks like it's yes still
about a ten thousand
vote difference again just conveniently
tipped to biden
trump's still commanding in pennsylvania
i don't even know if they're counting
again
really no movement wisconsin no no
movement at all in nevada
it's too early for those poll workers to
wake up
to or maybe there's some shenanigans
going on right now but nothing that's
all behind the scenes if it's happening
at all
nothing happening in front of the scenes
and nevada's or arizona rather still
seems pretty firmly
for biden some other good news
mitch mcconnell absolutely killed it he
crushed it
they poured money to defeat cocaine
mitch didn't matter cocaine mitch beat
him
let's cut now to cocaine mitch do you
wanna flick this
okay
okay do you want to play with okay oh no
shout out to my new friend
do you want to play with okay
that i felt was a powerful victory
speech
much better than anything we saw from
the other candidates all night it was
persuasive
democrats dumped you how much money they
dumped into defeating cocaine mitch
84 million dollars 84 million
for nothing for bupkus
let's see how about there are some other
senate races here it looks like
republicans are going to keep control of
the senate we'll see what happens
uh right now again no one's there
they're not calling this race
but the race in georgia between david
perdue
and jon ossoff david perdue has a
commanding
very commanding lead i can't imagine i
mean it's almost 200 000 votes
i can't imagine ossoff has any chance of
pulling that off
again unless there are some shenanigans
john ossoff you'll recall
is a complete democrat contrivance he's
like beto o'rourke but somehow less
successful
they ran him for congress and poured a
zillion dollars into him last time
for nothing he went nowhere then because
democrats fail
upwards he runs for senate and they
poured
even more money into him that time and
again
he went nowhere so that's pretty good we
picked up seats in the house that we
were told there's gonna be a blue wave
democrats take the senate democrats take
dows
that didn't happen pollsters were wrong
about that too so again it raises some
some interesting questions how is it
republicans did so well on the house
level on the senate level but
there's just that razor thin margin
pretty convenient drats and all those
key states in really only the key states
that
just had to go for biden pretty
strange to me other good news lindsay
grambo
lindsey graham 2.0 has won he won in
south carolina they poured money to
beating him by the way
beating uh lindsey graham 2.0 and that
didn't work at all he beat
jamie harrison that is pretty good news
some more great news those con artists
at the lincoln project
have been exposed actually they kind of
got what they came for
which is all their everything they tried
to do failed
frankly even if joe biden wins
it's not because of the lincoln project
nothing the lincoln project did would
have helped them the lincoln project was
running ads in
left-wing liberal places and they were
running billboards in new york they were
running ads on tv and morning joe on
msnbc in washington dc
obviously not to persuade any possible
republican voters or win any swing
states it was to raise money and they
did raise a lot of money
a lot of those guys in the lincoln
project the founders of it were out of
work gop strategists
and a lot of them had big debts some of
them were foreign
agents for russia i kid you not i kid
you not
foreign agents for russia and they
needed some money and they lined their
pockets from gullible democrats so i
in some ways i think i'm i'm sorry that
those con artists were able to make
money they got exactly what they came
for and they didn't deliver on the
senate races they didn't deliver on
house races
and if there is this razor thin margin
here for biden you can't
ascribe any of that to the lincoln
project so it bugs me that they
that they were able to get rich but it
is funny that they were able to milk
very very gullible democrats in that way
and of course the great news of the
night we get to get we get candace owens
coming over here
which is we you know if if you you don't
want to rely on the
establishment media to give you good
news i know
sometimes you got to make your own good
news so that's something that we tried
to do here
there are a couple things we've got to
look for in politics right now
and they are they're different and
ideally they will coincide one is you
want
precise analysis okay you want to be
listening to people
who are going to tell it to you like it
is and i i hope i think we're doing that
i
i'm certainly doing it to the best of
our ability not uh
calling it for trump or anything like
that uh giving you the precise down to
the numbers
but but also giving you both sides
giving you
what maybe the legacy press won't give
you so you want that precision you want
that accuracy
the other thing you want though is
courage now is a time for political
courage
because i think some people will want us
all to wait be very patient
and whatever whatever potentially
crooked schemes are going on
we'll find out about it later and then
we can fight about it later but but
later we'll be too late
later will be too late because the
narrative is dominating now
and there is going to be a uniform
narrative being pushed by the left
that joe biden has already won they
already they actually started pushing
the narrative before the election
even began and they have perpetrated
already a fraud in in stopping the
counting
in some key places and they've already
perpetrated a fraud
by upending our election laws
in in ways that are that would
disenfranchise people that would
you know if if people who ought not to
vote who don't have the right to vote or
people who you know maybe they're not
even really voters at all
uh do vote then that that takes votes
away from people who do have the right
to vote
and and that's a very bad thing and the
the left has constructed a system now
that is open for that and i think what
we need from conservatives we want that
precision we want that accuracy we want
that insight and we want courage to
stand up
against that narrative and stand with
our guy loyalty is a virtue and is
especially a virtue
in politics and and by the way just
just wisdom just share prudence would
show us
that the the very people who are telling
us all to give up right now
are the ones who have lied to us time
and time again who got everything wrong
last night even
even by the way even if biden were to
win the polls were still completely
wrong
no credibility at all they tried to
stage a coup d'etat in 2016.
they failed they tried for years and
years after that they used every
mechanism at their disposal
it is the prudent wise responsible thing
to do
to be highly skeptical of those guys
particularly after what we've seen in
the past few days
that does not mean that we come out and
say trump won that's it it's all over
we're not saying that but we're saying
we have every reason in the world
to be skeptical of the people that are
telling us that joe biden's just about
to win how neat and convenient is that
and we have every reason in the world to
stand with
our side our people this is an important
election
a lot hinges on it the fact that we were
able to keep the senate is a good thing
yeah i hope we keep the senate who knows
we still don't have final numbers on all
of these things
that's a good thing but we have got
to stand firm here
courage is a virtue fortune favors the
bold
and i'm glad that we have a president
who's willing to do that and i think we
ought to give him
absolutely just i'm not saying unjust
support but
just support responsible support
courageous support for conservatives
these are the chimes that try men's
souls and and this will probably be
heading to trial this will be heading
to the courts as somehow we all
suspected
it would i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton